bienvenue au 33 rue de chartres opéré en
yvelines c'est au coeur de cette
parcelle boisée composait d'une demeure
rurale et de son grand parc que
s'élabore un ambitieux projet social et
artistique dont le rayonnement s'étendra
sur le territoire alentours le 33 comme
on a l'habitude désormais de l'applet
c'est une propriété une immense
propriété de 9000 m²
idéalement situé à proximité du centre
de loisirs qu'on appelle la lsh et
surtout de la résidence pour personnes
âgées la rpc l'association saint jacques
qui a sollicité la commune du perray en
juin 2018 pour reprendre une gestion
directe du terrain avec pour objectif de
créer un lieu de vie sociale et
intergénérationnelle afin de faire
revivre ce site est en accord avec ses
exigences
la municipalité a lancé un appel à
projet en avril 2019
s'inscrivant dans une démarche de
participation citoyenne organisée sous
la houlette du collectif les gens du
lieu
les initiatives sélectionnées mais
l'ambition sociale culturelle
environnementale et de loisirs
parmi les cinq associations retenues
donc on a eu le lieu donc si on
proposait eu un projet permanent c'est à
dire de s'installer donc dans le dans le
bâtiment du 33 de faire des résidents
artistes de proposer également des des
rendez vous sur le site cycle et recycle
qui a pour ambition de proposer 2 de
l'accompagnement collectivité donc
notamment opéraient sur la question la
thématique de la mobilité troisième
association on a eu les pipelettes qui a
réalisé pas mal d'action
intergénérationnel notamment autour de
l'alimentation du bien manger
achetez grec qui a pour but de valoriser
et promouvoir le l'histoire du père est
le patrimoine même du territoire un peu
plus élargie et enfin la dernière c'est
présence qui a
pour principal objectif de faire des des
actions à destination des seniors
aujourd'hui ce projet collectif et
collaboratif se pose 10 et dessine une
offre innovante dont pourront bientôt
profiter les habitants
il a été convenu que la partie habitable
de la bâtisse seraient principalement
occupée par le lieu avec une partie
commune et également des chambres à
l'étagé pour résidence des artistes pour
la ce qui concerne la grange
il est envisagé d'y faire une petite
salle de spectacles à l'extérieur un
poulailler et un potager participatif
avec également une possibilité d'y
installer une ruche
de l'autre côté du bâtiment il est prévu
une activité réparation vélo il est
envisagé également un café associatif
la particularité de ce projet c'est que
sa dimension sa dimension culturelle au
service du social ce sont des
associations qui vont mettre en place en
plus des activités qui vont vraiment
participer au lien social
l'idée c'est vraiment d'en faire un lieu
vivant ouvert et convivial et qu'on soit
au service vraiment de tous les citoyens
le sud yvelines est assez dépourvus des
espaces de ce type là donc c'est
vraiment c'est un projet qui a un
caractère innovant fort c'est la raison
d'ailleurs pour laquelle on le projet il
est soutenu
aujourd'hui on est en est en discussions
avec le département des yvelines qui
souhaitent soutenir le projet notamment
sur la dimension sociale et culturelle
la région ile-de-france sur l'aspect
culturel et le parc naturel de la haute
vallée de chevreuse qui qui nous qui
nous soutient dans la mise en place de
ce projet dans sa conception
on attend avec impatience les premiers
rendez-vous publics du 33 fin 2020